あ
眠い
もう
手遅れかもしれませんこんにちははじめ社長です皆さん
5月に入りましたね五月病ご存知でしょうか今レイプを送ってくださった方も月1日の
もうお昼前の時点で眠いと言っておりますもう遅いかも知れませ
6月病って皆さんに聞いたことあると思うんですけども具体的にどんなもんなのかって
いうことをちゃんと知らないと思うんですよこんなちょっと五月病についてちょっと
話してみようと
ますそもそも五月病とは新入社員や大学の新入生や社会人などに見られる新しい環境に
適応できないことに起因する精神的な症状の総称でございます
まぁあれだまぁ簡単に言うとまあも五木走行軍みたいなところありますね新しい環境に
なってこんなかやる気満々じゃないか
でやる気満々でだーっであってゴールでべく
になってしまいますてゴールデンウィークってこ野菜が長いんでなんかう
て感じで休んじゃうと燃え尽きちゃってゴールデンウィーク中に4月からがんばってき
たその疲れが一気にどさっときてなんかもう学校とか仕事とか行きたくねえなとなり
ましたねーそういうちょっと理由が不明確な身体や心の主張をこれを五月病と言う
らしいでございます5月量はを打ってみたら大変危険な病気です
それで今日はちょっとあの僕なりに5月号
についてちょっと調べてみたんで5月病によくある症状ちょっとまとめてみました
この動画を見て少しでも10月病が怖いなと思っていただけると嬉しいです
ではどうぞ
ああああああ
4分
ああああああうん
ああああああ
me
うん
ええええええ
hey
ううぅううええええ
ああああああ
r
多摩コッツよどう改善していくかが課題になっているのでへ
まあいいところをどうやって税務
伸ばしていけるかえええええ
[拍手]
hey 切っなんですよ
ああああああ
はぁ
par
4日
あった
ブーバ言っておっブーブー俺行かない行かないおっ早く行かないよほらっ way
クロスまず1いやいや俺いいか迷うロス
以下だよ
やめろ俺もええ阿部選べる4ペラライアー4分いいようードゥ
それぞれ吹いていう
家
これやっていっ
言うのよを得だこちらのいわれやんだ言っ
はちょっとコウやんなよアーマー8だめだあっんじゃない
うん the やんないよあーじゃないんだやりなよ
ああああああ
そうだ
ポリポットは知ってますよね先輩
この前会社ねーなーと測器てたじゃないですか
あれの後その本人が言ってたんですけど
源さん一目惚れしちゃったらしいですよ
何すし半のエマワトソンが1な声ですよ
逆玉ですよ絶対付き合った方がいいですよ
えっ
wii
もう塗装
ああああああ
大学で結構使うことを教えてもらってたんで
ん
難しいけどねもちろん会社の亜マッサージ戦でもなんか
大先輩とかが
でこう教えてくれてるんだよ
もうね本当なんですかん a
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
始めおきなさい
うん
[音楽]
始めおきなさい会社をくれるでしょ
ん
持って
[音楽]
文学 a
ええええ
ううううううっうぅうういいわー
rar
[音楽]
ん
me
teal
car
ana あああっ
スカーフェイス打ったんじゃありません耳だ耳が聞こえないよってやばいすぎっ
沢山